COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER-
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU CALL
THE ROLL ON AVAILABLEFOR THE
NEED TO OKAY SO WILL BEGIN AS A
SUB COMMITTEE. WELCOME TO THE
FIRST SENATE BILL HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. WHETHER YOU'RE HERE
IN PERSON WATCHING VIRTUALLY OR
ON THE PHONE LINES I AM
GRATEFUL THAT YOU HAVE JOINED
US HERE ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER FLOOR. I WOULD
LIKE TO EXTEND A WARM WELCOME.
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER A KILO WEBER
THE NEWEST MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY'S HER FIRST
POLICY HEARING WITH THIS DOCTOR
WEBER WELCOME. I WILL NOT GO
OVER SOME OF THE KEY ELEMENTS
OF THE STRUCTURE OF TODAY'S
HEARING. DUE TO THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC WE ARE PRACTICING
FISCAL DISTANCING. IN THIS
HEARING AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATING. IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THOSE
PRESENT TODAY ON THE CHAMBER
FLOOR AND IN THE GALLERY WE ARE
HAVING TO PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON HEARING. IN THIS SPACE
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE. AUTHORS AND
A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF.
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX
FEET OF SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY IN THE
HEARING. THE ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND I WILL ASK YOU
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING WHAT YOU FINISHED
TESTIFYING TO RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
PRESERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON. AT A TIME.
IN ADDITION TO BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM. A REMOTE TESTIMONY.
STATION LOCATED IN THE CAPITAL
PARK IS AVAILABLE FOR
WITNESSES. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY. LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM AND ALSO ASK QUESTIONS OF
THESE WITNESSES. THERE MAY BE A
SLIGHT DELAY FROM THE STREAM
FROM THE ROPE REMOTE TESTIMONY.
STATION SO PLEASE BE PATIENT.
WE WILL ALSO BE USING THE A. T.
AND T. MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY
THERE AS WELL SO AGAIN I ASK
ALL INVOLVED TO REMAIN PATIENT.
THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER TO
CALL IN FOR THE HEARING. IS.
1-877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
OR MONITOR SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFIED IS BEGINNING. THEIR
BILL PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE. WE'LL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACE
IN THE QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE
TO A BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
POLICE ELIMINATE OF BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
SURE TO MEET YOUR PHONE WHEN
YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE
LEAD WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST THE BILL
YOU WILL REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE
IT WILL NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF.
UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. YOU HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
SERVICE PLEASE CALL THE
COMMITTEE OFFICE AT. ONE NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE
NINE SIX ZERO. AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL DO THEIR
BEST TO HELP YOU. PLEASE NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
ADDITIONALLY PLEASE NOTE THE
GUIDANCE FOR BILLS HEARD IN
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY FOR TO LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. TO LEAD WITNESSES
INOPERATIVE OPPOSITION TO SPEAK
FOR NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
EACH. STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND
ENTITIES THAT ARE EITHER IN
SUPPORT NOR IN OPPOSITION WILL
BE ALLOWED TO GIVE TESTIMONY
FOR NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
WHEN I CALLED FOR TWO WINNERS.
THE MEASURE AS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIES IN THE TWEENER
CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US AND IMPLEMENTING
THESE METHODS TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WHILE ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN THE
CHAMBER. MEMBERS OF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO RESPOND TO A ROLL CALL
ASK A QUESTION PROVIDE A
COMMENT. ASK YOU TO RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE SO STAFF CAN
ACTIVATED WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. IF YOU
WOULD ALSO STAND UP IN FACE THE
MICROPHONE WHEN SPEAKING TO
ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE
AND KIDS CAN BE RECORDED FOR
AUTHORS OF BILLS EACH MEMBER
PRESENTED TODAY WILL PROVIDE AN
OPENING AND CLOSING OUR TO
YOUR TO LEAD WITNESSES WILL BE
ANNOUNCED BY THE CHAIR. AND AS
I PREVIOUSLY STATED WILL HAVE
TWO MINUTES TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. BEFORE WE GO TO OUR
FIRST AUTHORED LET'S TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE TO
BUILD ON CONSENT. THEY ARE AS
FOLLOWS FILE ITEM TWO SB SEVEN
OH ONE FILE ITEM THREE AS
BEFORE THREE SIX. IS THERE A
MOTION FOR THE CONSECUTIVE. DR
CHOI MOVED THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MISTER BLOOM SECOND. YES OKAY.
ALL RIGHT I THINK WE MAY HAVE A
QUORUM NOW THAT MATTERS
SECRETARY COULD CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA PRESIDENT MEDINA HERE
CHILE CHOI HERE ARAMBULA. ON
JULY HERE BLOOM BLOOM HERE
GABRIEL IRWIN. IRWIN HERE
GABRIEL HERE KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE HAIR LOW SANTIAGO
CALAVERAS WEBER WEBER HERE. WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE'LL GO BACK TO THE MOTION-
MOVED BY DR CHOI FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND SECOND BY
MISTER BLOOM OF BENHAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI CHOI
I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM
BLOOM I GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN I HIGHLY. LEVINE. KILEY
I. LEVINE I LOW. SANTIAGO
BALLADARES WEBER WEBER I'D.
BOTH NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT WE LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WILL NOT HEAR BILLS AND FILED
ORDER BEGINNING WITH S. J. R.
ONE FILE ITEM ONE BY SENATOR
ALAN SENATOR ALLEN WHEN YOU ARE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERSUS-
WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO UPDATE
FACTS AND FIGURES BASED ON A
RECENT STUDENT LOAN. DATA
REPORTS THAT HAVE COME OUT AND
ALSO WHILE WE'RE FIXING A
DRAFTING ERROR. SO THIS
RESOLUTION CALLS ON OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO FORGIVE. A FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
STUDENT LOAN DEBT FOR STUDENT
BORROWERS ACROSS THE NATION- AS
FOLKS MAY KNOW THE COST OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IS RISING. AND
SIMULTANEOUSLY STUDENT LOAN
DEBT IN OUR STATE ACROSS THE
NATION IS SKYROCKETED-
INCREASING SOMETHING LIKE A
HUNDRED PERCENT OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS. SO TWENTY TWENTY.
OVER A NEARLY FIFTY MILLION
PEOPLE OWED MORE- AND- OWED
NEARLY TWO TRILLION DOLLARS. IN
STUDENT LOAN DEBT IN CALIFORNIA
OVER THREE MILLION BORROWERS-
NEARLY A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
THAT'S AN AVERAGE OF NEARLY
FORTY THOUSAND PER BORROWED TO
SPEAKING WITH ONE OF MEMBERS
ABOUT AND HIS- DEBT BURDEN- YOU
WE KNOW SO MANY CASES THAT ARE
IN THE- IN THE IN THE SIX AND-
AND EVER SAYS EVERS EVERY ONCE
IN AWHILE SAID EVEN SEVEN
FIGURES WHICH IS JUST-
DIFFICULT TO COMPREHEND.
STUDENT LOAN DEBT. AND THE
BURNING OUR ECONOMY AND ALL
SORTS OF WAYS IT DELAYS FOLKS
ABILITY TO FEEL COMFORTABLE
ENOUGH BUYING A HOME STARTING A
BUSINESS. REACHING OTHER
FINANCIAL MILESTONES INVESTING
EVEN HAVING CHILDREN- PEOPLE OF
SAID THAT THEY'RE LESS LIKELY
TO HAVE KIDS IF THEY HAVE A
ENORMOUS. DEBT BURDENS THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
STUDENTS OF COURSE HE'S
FAMILIES CANNOT HELP THEM PAY
FOR THEIR EDUCATION WHICH OF
AND- ACCENTUATES AND
EXACERBATES INEQUALITY IS FOR
MANY LOW INCOME AND FIRST
GENERATION. STUDENTS ARE
PRESIDENT OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS. AND
WOULD LIKE TO URGE THEM URGED
HIM TO CANCEL. A MODEST AMOUNT
OF STUDENT LOAN DEBT AS WE AS I
MENTIONED THERE ARE MANY THAT
WILL HAVE FAR FAR MORE STUDENT
AT THAT WILL NOT BE IMPACTED BY
THIS. HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF DOWN CALDERON
VICE PRESIDENT OF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS AT UC IRVINE. LET'S
HEAR FROM MISTER CALDERON. AT&T
MODERATOR THE LEAD WITNESS ON
THE LINE IS ALLEN CALDERON
EXTERNAL VICE PRESIDENT FOR HIS
SOCIAIS DID STUDENTS AT UC.
IRVINE MISTER CALDERON PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. HE
CHAIR MEDINA GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR ALAN FOR BRINGING
THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD MY NAME
IS ALAN CALDERON AND AS OF
YESTERDAY I AM A GRADUATE OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE. I AM PRESENT BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO OFFER YOU PASSED
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION ONE
CALLING ON PRESIDENT BINDING
AND CONGRESS TO FORGIVE FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF STUDENT
LOAN DEBT. WOULD BE EVER RISING
COST OF TUITION AND HOUSING AND
THEREFORE HIGHER AMOUNT OF LOAN
NEEDED HIGHER EDUCATION IS
BECOMING A DREAM DEFERRED. FOR
MANY STUDENTS INCLUDING MYSELF
WE'RE TALK FROM A YOUNG AGE
THAT ATTENDING COLLEGE IS A
NECESSITY FOR MANY STUDENTS
FROM A LOW INCOME BACKGROUND
THAT IS VERY MUCH THE MENTALITY
BUT OFTEN NOT A REALITY BECAUSE
OF THE HIGH COST OF ATTENDANCE.
THAT IS THE BURDEN BEYOND THE
COMPLETION OF OUR EDUCATION IF
ALL OF THE TO OUR CAREER AND
CAN BE A HUGE OBSTACLE TO HOME
OWNERSHIP OR STARTING A FAMILY
STUDENT LOAN DEBT CAN BE AND
OFTEN IS A LIFELONG ISSUE. IN
THE SUBJECT AN EDUCATION ISSUE
IT'S AN ECONOMIC JUSTICE ISSUE
FOR GIVING FOR CANCELING
STUDENT LOAN DEBT AND A
COMMITMENT TO THE STUDENTS
EDUCATION AND A COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING LOW INCOME FAMILIES
WHO HAVE BEEN TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF BY PREDATORY LENDERS.
CANCELING STUDENT LOAN DEBT IS
MORE THAN JUST AN EDUCATION
ISSUE AGAIN. IF AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE ISSUE. WELL SOMEONE FOR
PRO ALL OVER EXIST. THEY ARE
OFTEN FAR TOO LIMITED TO
CERTAIN FIELDS OR LACK
GUIDANCE. WHEN PEOPLE MAKE THE
DECISION TO START THEIR
COMMUNITY THEY SHOULD BE
AUTOMATICALLY PLACED. ON THE
TOP TO DEBT FORGIVENESS AN
OPPORTUNITY LIKE THIS ALSO NEED
TO BE FAR MORE EXPANSIVE.
MILLIONS OF STUDENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE SET TO BENEFIT WHAT
THE DEBT FORGIVENESS.
PARAMOUNT'S TO MILLIONS OF
DEGREES EDUCATED MIND ENTERING
THE COMPOST. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
EDUCATION ESPECIALLY HIGHER
EDUCATION. IS THE DREAM FOR
MANY HARD WORKING STUDENTS.
PLEASE HELP US ACHIEVE IT
EQUITABLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CALDERON WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO A PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NO ONE IN THE BACK OF
THE CHAMBER EITHER IN FAVOR OR
IN OPPOSITION OR AND TWEENER
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. ONE
EIGHTEEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
KAREN MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS TIFFANY MOCK AND ON
BEHALF OF CAL NONPROFIT WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AJ ARE. ONE
THANK YOU. NO OTHER LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER.
THANK YOU MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE STATE A POSITION OF
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES
IN A PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
YEAH THAT'S ONE OF THEM ZERO WE
DO HAVE A LINE IN Q. AND BE
JUST A MOMENT. LINE FIFTEEN ONE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHEN WE
CAN GOT FROM PLASTER COUNTY AND
I COULD NOT TO CLOSE THIS BILL
ANY STRONGER THAN I COULD RIGHT
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES INTERNAL. NO
THERE WITH HIS OWN DAUGHTER
LIVES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
MISTER ROGER RAIDER- ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES WHO ARE CLEANERS
ON THE PHONE. YOUR POSITION AS
A TRAINER IN A PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NONALIGNED
AND KIA. THANK YOU. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MR WITH. YES THANK
YOU AND GOODBYE THREE KIDS THAT
WENT TO COLLEGE I KNOW WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE BURDEN IT IS- TO
HAVE STUDENT LOAN DEBT AND
OBVIOUSLY MANY PEOPLE ARE
STAYING IN THEIR ENTIRE WORKING
LIFE PAYING OFF STUDENT LOANS
AND REYES RESOLUTION OFFICE
CERTAINLY I WILL SUPPORT IT BUT
WE DO HEAR ANECDOTALLY THAT-
DOING THIS WILL MOSTLY BENEFITS
A MIDDLE TO UPPER CLASS-
STUDENTS ARE WORKERS AND NOT
NECESSARILY- B. VISIT THE
STUDENTS THAT. WENT TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FIRST AND T
A STATE SCHOOL AFTER SO I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT WOULD BENEFIT
MOST FROM THIS. IF YOU IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS IT OR DRESSING
YOUR CLOTHES WHICH EVER YOU
KNOW I MEAN EITHER I APPRECIATE
THE COMMON GREAT DEAL I WILL
SAY- THAT. YOU KNOW KIDS WHO
COME FROM WEALTHY FAMILIES
TYPICALLY DON'T TAKE ON- AND-
YOUR LOANS. ARE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T NEED TO WRITE A MINUTES
ULTIMATELY EXPENSIVE TO TAKE ON
LOANS ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE- THE
INTEREST RATES THAT ARE
TYPICALLY GIVEN INCLUDING ON
THE PUBLIC LOANS- SO IT'S IT IS
TYPICALLY PEOPLE WHO COME FROM
LOWER INCOME OR- LOWER MIDDLE
INCOME BACK BACKGROUNDS. WHO
TAKE ON THESE LOANS SO AS TO BE
ABLE TO- YOU KNOW FINANCE THEIR
WAY THROUGH HIGHER EDUCATION-
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE BENEFITS
THAT ARE ACCRUED- BUT I DO
THINK CAN I GET TO THE POINT.
WHERE WE'RE WE'RE SURE AND ASK
PEOPLE TO ASK SERIOUS QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHETHER THE AMOUNT OF
LOAN DEBT REALLY IS JUSTIFIED.
HI HE IN SPITE OF THE GREAT
BENEFITS AT A COLLEGE DEGREE I
CAN BRING SOMEBODY AND I WILL
SAY THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO'VE GOT ENORMOUS LOAN THAT
YOU HAVEN'T EVEN YOU NEVER
FINISH A COLLEGE DEGREE-
OFTENTIMES BECAUSE OF THE- THE
FINANCIAL TROUBLE THEY PUT
THEMSELVES AND SO- YOU KNOW IF
YOU LOOK AT A LOT OF ARE WE YOU
KNOW THE PRESIDENT IS IN EUROPE
RIGHT NOW AND- IN IF YOU TAKE A
I WAS LEADING A PEACE
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS IN OUR ARE
PARTNERS IN EUROPE. I'D
TYPICALLY ONLY CHARGE A VERY
NOMINAL AMOUNTS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO GO TO COLLEGE BECAUSE
THEY RECOGNIZE WHAT IT SOCIETAL
BENEFITS THEY'RE IS ASSOCIATED
WITH WITH WITH WITH HAVING KIDS
GO TO COLLEGE AND GET THE
EDUCATION THE TRAINING OUT HERE
THAT I STATES WE'VE ENDED UP
CREATING SYSTEM THE COST SO
MUCH MONEY AND IT'S BECOME AN
ENORMOUS COST DRIVER IN SO MANY
ASPECTS OF OUR OF OUR LIFE IF
YOU LOOK AT AND HEALTH CARE FOR
EXAMPLE- AND THE THAT ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES WE HAVE
POLITICALLY TO PUTTING IN PLACE
A BETTER HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS
THE FACT THAT SO MANY OF OUR
DOCTORS. ARE WHO YOU KNOW I'VE
EVER COULD SO MUCH THAT THEY
FEEL THE NEED TO TURN BACK THE
MONEY THAT THEY LOST ASSOCIATE
WITH GETTING THEIR THEIR THEIR
MEDICAL EDUCATION A LOT OF OUR
EUROPEAN AND ASIAN COUNTERPARTS
YOU KNOW OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO GET DOT GO TO GO TO
BECOME DOCTORS BASICALLY GET TO
GO TO MEDICAL SCHOOL FOR FREE-
BECAUSE THERE'S A YEAH THERE'S
A RECOGNITION OF THE SOCIETAL
BENEFIT ASSOCIATED WITH
TRAINING GOOD HIGH QUALITY
DOCKS. SO AT YEAH THAT'S THE
GUY YEAH I WISH WE HAD A BETTER
SYSTEM- WE DON'T AND- AND FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE. THIS IS A WAY
TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT A
LOT OF. PEOPLE WHO COME FROM
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS. HAVE
TAKEN ON ENORMOUS DEBT JUST TO
BE ABLE TO GO. AND GET A HIGHER
EDUCATION. AS I SAY THE WEALTHY
YOU KNOW THOSE COMING FOR THE
WEALTHIEST FAMILIES DON'T HAVE
pTO AGREE DEBT- AND DONE AND
IT'S A RECOGNITION OF THE FACT
IS WE- WE ENGAGE IN ALL SORTS
OF. FORMS OF. SUPPORTS AND
WELFARE. AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
COLLUDING FOR MASSIVE
CORPORATIONS. IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THIS IS A THIS IS A
WORTHY- CADRE OF. YOUNG
AMERICANS WHO WE CAN HELP. TAKE
THAT DEBT BURDEN OFF THEIR
SHOULDERS SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY
START TO PUT THEIR RESOURCES
INTO BUILDING A LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES STARTING UP A NEW
BUSINESS BUYING A HOME- YEAH-
YOU HAVING KIDS- YOU KNOW
BUILDING A- A LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES SO AS TO BE ABLE TO-
TO. TO BOTH BENEFIT FROM THEIR
EDUCATION AND ALSO HOW OUR
SOCIETY BENEFIT FROM THEIR
EDUCATION. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALAN. DR CHOI. SENATE ALLEN-
THANK YOU FOR. EXPLAINING AND
OF MY QUESTIONS- TO MYSELF AND
TO YOUR SOFTPHONE MIGHT BE EVEN
THOUGH THE INTENT TO. OF A FOR
GIVING UP TO FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF- STUDENT DEBT- YOU
KNOW SO SUDDEN OPERABLE PEOPLE.
BUT THE I WONDER. THE ORIGINAL
PURPOSE OF- I SHOULD RUN LOAN
AND SO FOR THEM TO. I'LL BE
ABLE TO- GET THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION. IT COULD BE
BACHELOR'S DEGREE MASTER'S
DEGREE OF DOCTOR DEGREE. SO
THAT THE PERSON INDIVIDUAL WILL
HAVE A EARNING OUR THE ABILITY
TO. EARN THEIR WAGES ARE AND
THE PAY BACK. SO THAT THE MONEY
CAN BE UTILIZED FOR NEXT
GENERATION ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE NEED THE SAME. MONEY
FINANCIAL RESOURCES SO THE
TIRES THE CYCLE. ALL OF US OWN.
BUT IT IF YOU. FROM HERE. ON
DOWN THE ORIGIN OR INTENT- IS-
THE DAMAGES AND THE FUTURE HOW
LONG- THE GOVERNMENT.
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT THE WILL
WILL- NONSTOP BARI AND-
EXPECTING. A THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORDER ORDER IT WEIGHED BY OUR
EXAMPLE IS THAT THE MY SISTER
AND MY BROTHER IN LAW. THEY GOT
A JOB IN A RURAL AREA. OF A
PENNSYLVANIA- JUST BECAUSE OF
OUR GOVERNMENT'S- THOSE
CHILDREN LONG THAT THE WAIVER
IF THEY WENT TO THAT AREA.
UNDERSERVED AREA- BECAUSE IT
WAS A RURAL AREA NOT TOO MANY-
DOCTORS COME IN THERE FOR FIVE
YEARS SO- IF THE SERVER THERE
THAT WOULD BE WAIVED THE HOUSE
OF THAT'S WHY THEY TOLD US THAT
THE COUNTRYSIDE. AND THEY FELL
IN LOVE AND THE DESTINY CARE.
AND THOUGH THEY MADE ENOUGH
MONEY- AND- THEY ENJOY THEIR
LIFE THEIR- AND THE FEELING THE
NEED FOR THAT AREA SO THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF WAYS. WE CAN EXCUSE
THEIR LOANS. END UP GOVERNMENT
OF TEN UTILIZED TO VOICE OUR-
OUR PEOPLE OUT WITH A COLLEGE
EDUCATION. THEY ARE NOT
DIFFERENT GROUPS OF ALL
VOLUNTEER STUFF. SIRTIS
OVERSEAS WAS A PEACE CORPS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE CAN BE SENT TO
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND FOR FIVE
YEARS OR SEVEN YEARS ADJUSTING
AFTER MILITARY SERVICE AT THAT
AND YOU WANT THAT CAN BE
WAIVED. BUT THIS ONE JUST ARE
GIVING AWAY- THE INDIVIDUAL SO
THOSE ARE NO INCENTIVES AND
THEN HOW LONG. IF THIS-
RESOLUTION IS HAD TAKEN UP BY
THE CONGRESS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE A LOWLY BE FROM NOW ON. OR
RETROACTIVITY ACTIVELY IN THE
FUTURE HOW LONG FIVE YEARS WHAT
UP TO THIS YEAR ONE NEXT TEN
YEARS HOW LONG WILL IT
CONTINUE. THIS SYSTEM IS SO
TAKING AWAY ALL THE INCENTIVES
AND THE UNFAIRNESS. AND THE FOR
THE TAXPAYERS MONEY- AND I
THINK- WE HAVE A BETTER WAYS TO
A UTILIZED AT THE OLD THOSE OF
PEOPLE WITHOUT COLLEGES BECAUSE
TO WE ENCOURAGE THEM TO HIRE
THE OWNING ABILITY. TO HIGHER
EDUCATION BUT AFTER THAT. WITH
A DISS CONDITIONS OLDER WAYS
THE- YOU YOUR DATA I DON'T
THINK THIS IS NOT THE CORRECT
WAY TO GO. THIS OPINION. MR
LEVINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR- PRESENTING THIS
RESOLUTION STUDENT THAT IS A
PROBLEM IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A
PROBLEM PEOPLE THAT HAVE HAD A
LOT OF ISSUES WITH IT- NO NO
MATTER WHAT THAT SIZE- ON ANY
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS FOR
EXAMPLE- YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO
ADJUST. INTEREST RATES. AS
WELL- FROM CERTAIN BORROWERS
AND- AND SO I YOU KNOW THIS IS
A VERY SYMBOLIC BILL ASKING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO SPEND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MONEY A
CERTAIN WAY I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S WIDELY. IT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE- TO JUST SAY ANYONE WHO
HAS AS MUCH AS FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF DEBT- IF YOU JUST BE
WIPED AWAY- BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
WE DO SUBSIDIZE PEOPLE'S
EDUCATION QUITE A BIT.
PARTICULARLY THROUGH ALL OF OUR
EFFORTS THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
MADE POSSIBLE THE YEARS. IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM- I
DON'T HAVE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT OTHER SIDE OF IT I THINK
YOU KNOW IF WE WANT TO. SUPPORT
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES- THAT
THAT THAT THAT THAT'S FINE BUT-
WE ALSO DON'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
HOW MANY WAYS. HOW MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS FAMILIES SUPPORT
STUDENTS OR STUDENTS SUPPORT
THEMSELVES FOR EXAMPLE. THOSE
WHO ARE WORKING AT THE SAME
TIME IS GOING TO SCHOOL. OR
THOSE WHO ARE. PUTTING THEIR
OWN SAVINGS AND SAID INTO THEIR
CHILDREN'S COLLEGE EDUCATION
RATHER THAN INTO THE RETIREMENT
SECURITY. WHICH IS A HUGE
PROBLEM FOR FAMILIES. THAT THIS
DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT AT
ALL AND- YOU KNOW I TRY TO KEEP
UP ON THE LITERATURE SOME HIS
BOTH TRYING TO SAVE FOR MY
CHILDREN'S COLLEGES WELL AS
SUPPORT OF MY OWN FUTURE. AND
THAT BORROWING MONEY FOR
COLLEGE IS A BETTER INVESTMENT
THAN BECAUSE YOU CAN'T BORROW
MONEY FOR RETIREMENT. SO YOU
KNOW WE'RE YOU KNOW HOW ARE WE
INFORMING PEOPLE ABOUT THAT THE
FINANCIAL DECISIONS THAT
THEY'RE MAKING ON BEHALF OF
THEIR FAMILIES- AND SO I THINK-
I THINK IT'S KIND OF A BLUNT
INSTRUMENT I MEAN I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY AND- YOU
KNOW YOU CAN CONTINUE WORKING
HUMBOLDT. THE RESOLUTION WHICH
I'M SURE. WILL NOT GET FURTHER
THAN THE MEN'S FOR TAKING- BUT
YOU KNOW IT'S A GOOD BECAUSE WE
WANT TO HELP PEOPLE YOU KNOW
WHO ARE GOING TO COLLEGE. NOT
NECESSARILY- THE INSTRUMENT TO
HELP- CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE
AMERICAN FAMILIES REALLY PLAN
FOR BOTH THEIR THE RETIREMENT
SECURITY. AS WELL AS- HAVING
CAREERS WHERE YOU'RE MAKING
MORE MONEY THAN PEOPLE THAT
DON'T GO TO COLLEGE SO. ON YOU
KNOW THAT'S THE COST OF YOU
KNOW THE OPPORTUNITY GOING TO
COLLEGES ARE A LITTLE BIT MORE-
IF YOU HAVE TO TAKE ON SOME
DEBT. MAYBE YOU'VE MADE A
RATIONAL DECISION NOT TO GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR NOT TO
WORK WHILE GOING TO COLLEGE. OR
TO TAKE ON THE DEBT THAT YOU'VE
DECIDED TO TAKE ON- SO- SO I
THINK. YOU KNOW IT'S JUST A
IT'S A LOT MORE COMPLICATED
THAN JUST ST EVERYONE GETS
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS- BECAUSE
YOU KNOW LIKE I'VE GOT A-
COUSIN IN GERMANY. WHOSE SON IS
GOING TO GO TO A GERMAN
UNIVERSITY BECAUSE IT'S FREE.
AND AND YOU KNOW WHAT IF WE
JUST SAID. EVERYONE WHO'S BORN
IN CALIFORNIA IT WOULDN'T BE
NICE CAN GO TO UC OR CSU. WE
HAVE SAID THIS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIANS- BUT IT'S JUST A
BIT OF A BLUNT- BLUNT
INSTRUMENT I THINK HE'S A LOT
MORE WORK PARTICULARLY IF. IF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S GOING
TO DO SOMETHING ON THIS PROBLEM
THANKS. THANK YOU MR LEVINE.
SAY NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATOR ALAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE WELL I LISTEN I
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION AND I WILL SAY- OF
COURSE IT'S A BLUNT INSTRUMENT
IT'S IN IT'S ABSOLUTELY PERFECT
BECAUSE OUR SYSTEM IS SO
FUNDAMENTALLY IN PERFECT. YOU
KNOW I WOULD MUCH PREFER THE
GERMAN MODEL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
WHERE WHERE WHERE WHERE THERE'S
A SOCIETAL RECOGNITION OF A
SOCIETY WIDE BENEFIT ASSOCIATED
WITH- FREE TO LOW COST HIGHER
EDUCATION. FOR FOR THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST AND FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
OF ALL BACKGROUNDS SO IS TO
PROVIDE AVENUES. OUR FOR SOCIAL
MOBILITY. AND YOU KNOW AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW IN GERMANY AND
ELSEWHERE IN EUROPE THERE'S A
LOT MORE SOCIAL MOBILITY I MEAN
THE CHANCES. OF GETTING. OF
MOVING UP THE LADDER HERE IN
UNITED STATES IF YOU'RE IN THE
LOWEST QUINTILES- IS SO MUCH
LOWER THAN IN- IN GERMANY OR IN
OTHER PARTS OF EUROPE IN SPITE
OF THE- OUR FEALTY TO THE
AMERICAN DREAM. I WHICH WHICH
KIND OFCONTINUES TO SELL THIS
IDEA THAT THAT THAT THERE IS
SOCIAL MOBILITY BUT THERE
ACTUALLY IS FAR LESS. THAN IN
THE COUNTRIES THAT YOU
MENTIONED ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
REALLY DO THINK THAT A LOT OF
THAT HAS TO DO WITH THEIR-
SOCIETAL AND POLICY- A- FOCUS.
WHEN IT COMES TO I'M PUTTING IN
INVESTMENTS UPFRONT INVESTMENTS
IN YOUNG PEOPLE I BOTH
EVERYTHING FROM EARLY CHILDHOOD
TO- TO THE ENTIRE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM IS REALLY THE HIGHER
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. OUT SO. I
DON'T THINK I WOULD SAY IS THAT
WHILE YOU WELL IT'S TRUE THAT
THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN A PROBLEM
IT'S ALL IT'S GOTTEN SO MUCH
WORSE IT'S SO MUCH WORSE
MEMBERS. THEN EVEN WHEN MOST OF
US. WERE GOING TO COLLEGE I
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA. IF
YOU COMPARE THE NUMBERS TODAY
TO WHAT THEY WERE BACK IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE. V. V.
THE AVERAGE AMOUNT OF DEBT HAS
GONE UP OVER TWO HUNDRED
PERCENT. EVEN THOUGH THE
SALARIES. HAVE ONLY GONE UP
ABOUT. ABOUT FIFTY PERCENT. SO
THERE'S BEEN A HUGE. A HUGE
SPIKE IN THAT INCREASE. I. SO
MUCH MORE THAN IT WAS BEFORE
AND I'VE BEEN AND I WAS I'M
TALKING IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE IF YOU GO BACK. TO SOME
OF THE OLDER TIMERS HERE IN THE
BUILDING. YOU'LL FIND THAT THEY
THEY THEY WERE GOING TO SCHOOL
TIME WHEN THE TUITION LEVELS
WERE SIMILAR TO WHAT THEY ARE
GERMANY AND THEY REALLY
BENEFITED AND THEY WERE ABLE TO
PUT ALL THAT EXTRA. YOUR BRAIN
POWER AND MONEY THAT THEY
EARNED INTO BUILDING OUR
ECONOMY AND GROWING OUR ECONOMY.
TO MY FRIEND THE VICE CHAIR I'M
IF YOU WOULD BE MEANINGFUL FOR
MY REPUBLICAN FRIENDS I'M
ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO WORK ON
EITHER A NEW RESOLUTION OR
TWEAKING THIS ONE. TO REALLY
FOCUS IN ON A ROBUST. LOAN
FORGIVENESS SYSTEM FOR
EVERYTHING FROM PUBLIC SERVICE
OR LOW PAID- WORK THE PEOPLE
TAKE ON IT'S TRUE THAT A
COLLEGE DEGREE- OFTEN PROVIDES
PEOPLE WITH A HIGHER SALARY BUT
CERTAINLY NOT ALWAYS. ARE LOTS
OF PEOPLE TAKE THEIR THEIR
DEGREE AND THEY DON'T GET PAID
ANYWHERE NEAR AS WELL AS THEY
COULD BECAUSE THEY PURSUE THEIR
PASSIONS ARE THEY GO OFF AND
DO. A LOWER PAID WORK
OFTENTIMES ARE LOWER PAID WORK
REALLY DOES HAVE AN TRêN
CREDIBLE SOCIETAL BENEFIT EVEN
IF IT'S NOT A HIGH FINANCIAL
BENEFIT FOR THE WORKER. I'VE
AND SO WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT. IF THERE'S A IF THERE'S A
WAY THAT YOU AND I CAN WORK ON
ON ON A MEASURE THAT WOULD
REALLY TARGET. ARE THOSE FOLKS
WHO DECIDE TO TAKE ON LOWER
SALARIES- WHO DO WHO HAVE GONE
TO LOWER SERVED AREAS AND IN
RURAL PARTS OF THE COUNTRY AS
YOU DISCUSSED. I'D BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU ON- ON A
RESOLUTION THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD REALLY ZERO IN ON THOSE
ON THOSE PEOPLE WHO'VE WHO'VE
TAKEN ON THOSE CHALLENGES AND
BURDENS AND- AB SO I CERTAINLY
HAVE AN OPEN DOOR. I AM NOT I
DON'T HAVE ANY ILLUSIONS THAT
THIS RESOLUTION IS ALL JUST A
RESOLUTION AND- ULTIMATELY
GONNA BE THE FELLOW THAT
GOVERNMENT'S DECISION EVEN IF
IT. IF IT. PURSUES A PER.
EXACTLY ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT
I'VE CALLED FOR- THESE THESE
BROAD PROBLEMS THAT WE
DISCUSSED TODAY IT WOULD NOT BE
SOLVED BUT I DO THINK. IT WILL
GO. IT WILL TAKE ASSIST. A STEP
FURTHER. TOWARD TOWARD HELPING.
YOU THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WE
TOLD. WE SAID IT AND GO GET A
COLLEGE EDUCATION EVEN THOUGH
YOU CAN'T AFFORD IT BECAUSE YOU
DON'T COME FROM A WEALTHY
FAMILY. TAKE ON THAT DEBT
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE WORTH
IT FOR YOU AND YET NOW THEY'RE
FINDING THEMSELVES IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY CAN'T EVEN
AFFORD A HOUSE THEY CAN'T EVEN
START A BUSINESS THEY CAN'T.
RAISE A FAMILY AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE BUT
I AM UNDER NO ILLUSIONS THAT
THIS IS GOING TO SOLVE THE
MASSIVE PROBLEMS THAT I HOPE WE
ALL WORK TOGETHER. TO HELP TO
SOLVE TO MAKE OUR SYSTEM MORE
FAIR. ON SO WITH THAT I
CERTAINLY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE BUT I ALSO RESPECT
THE OPPOSITION AND CONCERNS.
THAT HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED HERE
TODAY. IN THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALAN. THE RISING
COST OF HIGHER EDUCATION AS
WE'VE SAID HERE THIS AFTERNOON
HAS BECAUSE STUDENTS TO SEEK
ADDITIONAL METHODS OF PAYING
THEIR EDUCATION THE ON
SCHOLARSHIPS AND GRANTS AND
CURRENTLY THERE ARE ROUGHLY
FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO
HAVE FEDERAL AND PRIVATE
STUDENT LOANS EQUATING TO CLOSE
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN DEBT. SO
RELEASING GRADUATES FROM THE
BURDEN OF PAYING FOR STUDENT
LOANS ALLOW AS OUR SENATORS
SAID INVEST IN THE FUTURE LIFE
MILESTONES LIKE BUYING A HOUSE
INVESTING IN THE ECONOMY SO I
THANK THE SENATOR SENATOR ALAN
FOR IT- ACCEPTING THE-
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING AS J. R. ONE WITH
THE HOPES OF THE PRESIDENT
UNITED STATES WILL TAKE SWIFT
ACTION TO RELIEVE STUDENT DEBT.
WE'VE HAD A MOTION BY DOCTOR
RUMBLE- A SECOND BY. MR LOW-
THE MOTION BEFORE IS TO IS TO
BE ADOPTED AS AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR STE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. MEDINA
HI MEDINA HI CHOI CHINA-
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM
BLOOM HI GABRIEL GABRIEL I
IRWIN IRWIN I KILEY. LEVINE
LEVINE I LO LO I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I KNOW THERE IS. HELLO
THERE IS NOT VOTING WEBER.
WEBER HI. THAT IS NINE ONE NINE
ONE THE BILL IS OUT I WILL KEEP
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THE
FINAL BILL IN FILE ORDERS S. B.
SEVEN THREE SEVEN BY A SENATOR
LEE MON. BUT SEEN HER. WILL BE
THE FINAL BILL.
OKAY GLENDALE
OUT ON THE CONSENT. WE'RE GOING
TO DO ADD ONS FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OKAY THIS IS THE A
CONSENT CALENDAR LOW. LOW
ALLIES SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
BALLADARES ELDERS HI THE BILL
HAS. TWELVE ZERO TWELVE ZERO
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT WELCOME
SENATOR LEóN. WELCOME BACK TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. THANK YOU
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS IT
FEELS GREAT TO BE ON THIS FLOOR
WITH YOU ALL AGAIN. SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN UPDATE THE
GOVERNING STATUTE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT OPPORTUNITY
THIS PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS
KELSO. TO BOTH REFLECT THE POST
SECONDARY AXIS NEEDS OF TODAY'S
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND TO
ALIGN EXISTING BEST PRACTICES
OF EACH. OF THE COUNTS ARE
PROJECTS I HAVE A PERSONAL
UNDERSTANDING. I'M CATCHING MY
BREATH. OF HOW CALCIUM OPERATES
ITS MISSION PRIOR TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE I WORK FOR CAL SOAP
IN MY DISTRICT ASSISTING
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
HOW THEY CAN ACHIEVE HIGHER
EDUCATION. THERE ARE CURRENTLY
SIXTEEN HOUSE ARE PROJECTS WITH
A VARYING RANGE. OF SERVICES TO
STUDENTS IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING NOT ONLY
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE. BUT ALSO TUTORING
AND ACADEMIC SUPPORT. SB THIRTY
SEVEN REDUCES DUPLICATION OF
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAMS LIKE
AVID TRIO. EUROPE THAT ARE
READY PROVIDEACADEMIC SUPPORT
PROGRAMMING BY FOCUSING HEALTH
SERVICE PROJECT ON FINANCIAL
AID ASSISTANCE. AN AREA WHERE
THEY HAVE EXPERTISE AND
EXPERTISE FOUND LESS OFTEN HIGH
SCHOOLS. SB SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
ALSO MAKES DATA COLLECTION AND
PROGRAM EVALUATION CONSISTENT
ACROSS EACH OF THE COUNTS ARE
PROJECTS TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE
AND TARGETED OUTREACH. AS WELL
AS INFORM CURRENT AND FUTURE
FUNDING DECISIONS. AT WITH US
TODAY WE HAVE A YES YOU'LL-
BIAS DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNCIL. AND MANY
RODRIGUEZ- WITH EDUCATION TRUST
WEST IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEE BONE AT&T
MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
FIRST LEAD WITNESS WHO'S
CALLING AND FOR SB SEVEN THREE
SEVEN MR MANNY RODRIGUEZ SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE ASSOCIATE FOR THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST. MISTER
RODRIGUEZ PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEDINA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MANNING RODRIGUEZ HERE IN THE
APPALACHIAN BECAUSE WHAT. WE
ARE A RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY
NONPROFIT WORKS TO EXPOSE
NOBODY KEEP THE INJUSTICES AND
INEQUITIES IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS IN COLLEGE COLLEGE
COACH FIRST OF LIKE TO THINK
CENTER THE MOST AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. EIGHTY W. A. R.
TO CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT SB
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN WHICH SEEKS
TO MODERNIZE THE KALISPELL
PROGRAM I SHE SAID BY FOCUSING
IN ON FINANCIAL LITERACY AND
DIRECTLY SUPPORTING STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES AND COMPLETING THE
FASTER WELL. CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT APPLICATION. THE IS CLEAR.
ACCESS TO TWO POINT AID IS KEY
IN OPENING DOORS TO POST
SECONDARY ASPIRATIONS S.
FINANCIAL BARRIERS INCLUDING
INSUFFICIENT AVAILABLE EIGHT.
SHE POSSIBLE COLLEGE READY LOW
INCOME STUDENTS FROM ATTENDING
A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE 90% OF
STUDENTS WHO COMPLETE THE FAST
TO ENROLL IN COLLEGE DIRECTLY
FROM HIGH SCHOOL COMPARED TO
JUST 55% OF NOT COMPLETED. LAST
WEEK COMPLETING THE FAST THAT
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
STUDENTS PERSIST IN A COLLEGE
COURSE WORK AND OBTAIN A DEGREE.
DESPITE THE CLEAR CONNECTION
BETWEEN FINANCIALLY ACCESS TO
COLLEGE ATTENTION ATTENDANCE
AND RETENTION. NEARLY HALF A
MILLION CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS DID NOT COMPLETE A
FOSTER KID IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS. AN ESTIMATED FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN STATE
AND FEDERAL ABLE TO LEFT ON THE
TABLE. SHE ALSO PROGRAMS ONE
CALIFORNIA'S PRIMARY OUTREACH
PROGRAMS WHICH CAN SUPPORT
STUDENTS AND PARENTS AND
COMPLETING THIS APPLICATION.
THERE FOR MODERNIZING IT WOULD
IMPROVE FINANCIAL LITERACY AND
ACCESS AMONGST. VARIOUS
UNDERSERVED POPULATION. THROUGH
THEIR SIX GREEN CONCERT. WE
NEED TO MIX BUILD MOMENTUM TO
INCREASE COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
BY PASSENGERS OF MODERNIZATION.
THAT IS ESPECIALLY TRUE NOW AS
CALIFORNIA CONSIDERS A
UNIVERSAL FAST- INTO THE
COMPLETION PROPOSAL. THIS IS
JUSTIN EDUCATION ACT WILL ISSUE
IS ALSO AN ECONOMIC COMPARED HI
POSTSECONDARY SEGMENTS ARE
ENGINES OF ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
CALIFORNIA WILL BENEFIT
ECONOMICALLY A POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION IS ECONOMICALLY.
FEASIBLE TO ALL STATE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND WE
HOPE TO HAVE YOUR EYES OPEN
THIS BILL TODAY. THANK YOU
THE SECOND LEAD WITH THIS
CALLING IN. BUSINESS HE SAID
VICE THE DIRECTOR OF CALLS SO
LA. IS BIAS PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
SEVENTY NINE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS THE SENATE BIASED AND I
AM THE PROJECT DIRECTOR OF THE
HEALTH BILL BAILEY PROGRAM. THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT OPPORTUNITY
AND ACCESS PROGRAM IS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE
COMMUNITIES IT SERVES. IN LOS
ANGELES WE SERVE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES WHO
LIVE IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO PROVIDE
IMPORTANT TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO
THE COUNSELORS AND STAFF AT OUR
HEALTH ABILITY SCHOOLS MANY OF
WHOM ARE OVERSTRETCHED AND
OVERWHELMED. WE SUPPORT
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS
BY PROVIDING ONE ON ONE COLLEGE
AT BIKING AND AN ARRAY OF
FINANCIALLY FOLLOW TO SENIORS
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND THROUGH
THEIR FIRST YEAR OF POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. HELP HAVE
ALSO. A UNIQUE COLLEGE GOING
CULTURE THROUGH THE HIRING OF
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
STUDENTS TO SEPARATE COACHES TO
THE STUDENTS SERVED BY THE
PROGRAM. THE SENSE OF COMMUNITY
INTEREST TO HELP THE POSITIONS
OF THE WELL TO BE THE FINANCIAL
AID RESOURCE STUDENTS
DESPERATELY NEED AND DESERVE.
FIGURING OUT HOW TO PAY FOR
COLLEGE CONTINUES TO BE LEADING
VERY ARE TOO MANY OF OUR
PROMISING STUDENTS. THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE FACT THAT AND
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION ALSO DETER MANY
FROM SEEKING EIGHT DESPITE
BEING ELIGIBLE. YOUR TO
FINANCIALLY CAN BE ADDRESSED BY
LEVERAGING HEALTH OF
FINANCIALLY EXPERTISE AND
REFOCUSING HELP THE PROJECT TO
BECOME THE STATE'S LEADING
FINANCIAL AID AWARENESS
LITERACY AND ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. UNDER SB SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN TULSA BALLET WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION
COMPLETION. HELP MIDDLE SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WITH
TARGETED COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
WORKSHOPS. AND ALLOW IT TO FILL
THE FINANCIALLY GAP BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
FINANCIALLY WORKSHOPS WE OFFER
TO SCHOOLS AND PROGRAMS WHO DO
NOT HAVE THE FINANCIAL AID
EXPERTISE. LASTLY IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT IT BE SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN BE ENACTED TO HELP
STUDENTS NAVIGATE THE FINANCIAL
AID PROCESS AND GRADUATE WITH
LESS STUDENT DEBT. AND IN TURN
HELP INCREASE CALIFORNIA'S
COLLEGE GOING POPULATION. FOR
THESE REASONS I URGE YOU ALL TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF SENATE BILL
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THEY
GIVE IS BIASED WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. SEE NO
WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER NEITHER IN FAVOR NOR IN
OPPOSITION OR TWEETERS WILL
MOVE THE PHONE LINES. AT&T
MODERATOR THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE OR IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU THE STATE
SUPPORT PRESS THREE SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN THAT
COMMANDOS ONES AND THEN THE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE TWENTY TWO TO
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON ERICA
ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE.
TWENTY FIVE. MEDIA REPRESENT
THEM OF THE EVERGREEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BY. NINETEEN
GOOD AFTERNOON HELLO HELLO GO
DOWN WITH WIDENING GROUP
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TWENTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
MEMBERS MAY WASHINGTON WITH THE
CAL STATE UNIFICATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE SEVENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JEFF FLOCK OF REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER BACH OF. THANK. SIXTEEN
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DANIELLE RODRIGUEZ CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEARING AID COMMISSION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. LINE.
TWENTY THREE. SIR TWENTY THREE
IS YOUR DEVICE ON MUTE. MOVING
ON ARE THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINE'S BEEN Q. THANK YOU. MR
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THE
STATE A POSITION OF OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO PLEASE. THERE ARE NO LINES
IN QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
TWEETERS ON THE LINE. TO SHARE
POSITION OF TWEENER PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
USING YOUR PHONE WE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MISTER
INTERNAL LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
THEN WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS DR
RUMBLE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS LEGISLATION
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE WHICH
EXPANDS UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
THAT CAL SOAP SERVICE TO
INCLUDE HOUSEHOLDS OF MIXED
IMMIGRATION STATUS. HOWEVER I
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE IS AN
UNDERSTANDABLE HESITANCY FOR
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS AND
APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL AID DUE
TO CONCERNS THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS MAY BE DIVULGED. I KNOW
THAT THE STATE PROTECTS SUCH
INFORMATION BUT I WAS CURIOUS
IF THE AUTHOR HAS CONSIDERED
SPECIFYING AS PART OF CAL SOAPS
OUTREACH INCLUSION OF
INFORMATION ON STATE DATA AND
PRIVACY PROTECTION
REQUIREMENTS. TO ENCOURAGE
INDIVIDUALS FROM THESE
COMMUNITIES TO APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL AID. BUT THE QUESTION
AND- WE HAVEN'T EXPLICITLY IS
THOUGHT OF PUTTING SOMETHING
AND I'M HAPPY TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT I THINK
THAT THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT AS
SOMEONE WHO WORKED. UP FOR THE
PROGRAM PRIOR TO BEING IN THE
LEGISLATURE I A- I KNOW HOW
MUCH WE TRACKED IT STUDENT
INFORMATION WITH STUDENT ID
NUMBERS IN ORDER TO AVOID A
SOME OF THE PERSONAL
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION AND SO
I'M HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION TO UNDERSTAND HOW
TO BETTER DO THAT AND ALSO
ENCOURAGE- ARE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
STATE AID- TO ALSO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE PROGRAM. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. WHO HAD-
MOTION BY DOCTOR RUMBLE- SECOND
BY MR LOW- MISLI MON IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SO I WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM ALL
HIGH. FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
ALL STUDENTS HAVE KNOWLEDGE AND
ASSISTANCE IN ENSURING THAT
THEY CAN ATTEND COLLEGE SHOULD
THEY- CHOOSE I SUPPORT THEM
THIS MEASURE. AND ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR TO WORK WITH MY
COMMITTEE STAFF IN ADDRESSING
THE COMMENTS ON PAGES FIVE AND
SIX OF THE EIGHT ANALYSIS SO WE
HAD A MOTION BY DOCTOR RUMBLE
AS SECOND BY MR LOW. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MADAM SECRETARY IF
YOU'D PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA AYE CHOI.
SORRY NOT VOTING ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM BLOOM I
GABRIEL APRIL AYE IRWIN- WHEN I
KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LOW. LOW
I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I CALAVERAS.
WELL THERE IS I WEBER. WEBER
AVE. THE VOTES TEN ZERO GEN
ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT. THANK
AND REGULATIONS WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ANY ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS. AND
WITH THAT WE'LL SEE IF WE NEED
TO GO ON TO. ANY ANY ABSENT
MEMBERS. MR KILEY WHO WAS IN
HERE WELL. WE WILL KEEP WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR. FIVE
MINUTES WAITING FOR A ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL MY
GRATITUDE TO THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE STAFF THE RULES
COMMITTEE STAFF LEGISLATIVE
DATACENTER THE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR AND ALL WHO ENSURE
THE HEARING COULD TAKE PLACE ON
A SPECIALLY THANK MY COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK
COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION.
THANK YOU ALL.
COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION IS A DURING.